hello everybody welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll today
we have Adam Rutherford all the way from
the United Kingdom
Adam is a geneticist by training but
he's become also an extremely successful
science communicator it seems to me
sometimes like every professor of
science in England or the rest of the
United Kingdom also has you know a
column in The Guardian a radio show on
the BBC etc at least Adam does all of
those things and he's also the author of
a number of very interesting books he
has a brand new book out which I tease
him a little bit on the program I don't
love the title of the book which is
called humanimal the idea behind the
book is to relate human beings and how
we are and how we behave to other
animals right human beings are animals
just like everyone else we think we're
special
there are ways in which human beings are
different from other animals for example
other animals don't have podcasts at
least they don't host podcasts as far as
I know someone in the comments I'm sure
is gonna correct me on that
misimpression but it turns out maybe it
shouldn't be surprising that it's
actually very difficult to pinpoint what
it is about human beings that makes us
special you know our brains are big but
other animals have big brains we use
fire but guess what there are birds that
use fire for purposes of their own other
animals use tools other animals use
versions of language so we learn a lot
about human beings in our relationship
to the rest of the world by looking and
studying the behavior of animals and of
course atoms also a geneticist so we
don't just let eat behavior but also
where human beings came from and perhaps
because he's a professor perhaps because
he's a science communicator perhaps
because he's written books on other
topics as well such as synthetic biology
and the origin of life
Adam is a great talker he's someone who
has a lot of opinions about lots of
different things so compared to other
episodes of mindscape this one is not as
focused on the original theme that I had
in mind but I think that's a feature not
a bug I think it's a good wide-ranging
rambling conversation where we talk
about what life really is how genetics
works how genetic is genetics is
misunderstood in the public you know the
role the
second law of thermodynamics - what it
means to be alive all sorts of
interesting things come up in this so
this is a more synthetic than focused
episode of mindscape but that's good we
should cleanse the palate every once in
a while with something exactly like that
and Adam certainly a lot of fun to
listen to I think this is going to be an
entertaining as well as insightful
podcast so let's go
[Music]
Adam Rutherford welcome to the mindscape
podcast guys who talked to you Sean so
you're a geneticist by training the most
recent book though has to do with more
the intellectual / cultural evolution of
the human species but I know that you
did write a previous book that was more
biological strictly speaking is that
right yeah that's exactly right in fact
so that the last book which was called a
brief history of everyone who ever lived
was the application of genetics to human
prehistory and human history so that the
whole premise was that we've suddenly
given ourselves access to this new
historical source which is our DNA and
the book is about what the first half
the first off is about some sort of
refiguring human evolution is through
prehistory and how that has
revolutionized our understanding of our
trajectory to here from there and the
second half of that book is about using
DNA as a sort of historical source to
sit alongside the more traditional ways
of knowing the past which is archaeology
and paleontology and the paper trail and
you know just just that the things of
history so it's very much a book about
genetics were you know genetics as a
historical source a historical source
which is different to those other ones
because it's it's one that everyone has
it's it is it is the story of all
humanity that the the slightly bombastic
title is it's sort of metaphorically
true because within every cell of your
body you contain the entire history not
just of your family but of of our
species of of our you know greater
family groups within the evolutionary
tree and ultimately or all life on Earth
so that was that was a brief history and
there was a single line in the final
chapter of brief history which sort of
triggered me thinking about what the
next book was going to be and a you know
this is a writer that sometimes you just
get it mmm something seeds gets planted
and you can't shake it and it was it was
a line from well you know we've talked
about films before we're both we both
love love a pop culture and
and I quote films all the time in my
work mostly for my own amusement
occasionally must keep the author
self-amused otherwise what's the point
of reading a book exactly exactly but it
has got to the stage is sort of disease
like stage for me where I'm quoting
things without necessarily realizing I'm
doing it so I wrote the line which was
everyone is special which is another way
of saying that no one is and I sent it
up to my editor and when I got like the
feedback from the first draft she said I
like the way you quoted that film in the
last in the last chapter and I hadn't
even realized I don't do you know what
film it is I do but only because I've
watched your video yes it's from the
Incredibles yes which a so I'm sort of
slightly pleased and slightly
embarrassed that I've done this but
anyway the point is that it was that
idea of human essentialism of human
uniqueness of our of our incredibly
anthropocentric view of the universe
where do we position ourselves now with
this new found information about
genetics about our cultural evolution
about the evolution of our minds this
whole trajectory of science over the
last several hundred years has been to
inch ourselves back into nature having
spent a long time thinking of ourselves
as separate from nature hey you know a
this is a cosmologists you know it's the
first steps were to heliocentrism rather
than yeah thinking of the earth
revolution happens in every subfield of
science at some point exactly so and
that's that's it for us for the
biologists it was it was just a concept
of evolution which of course was was
solidified by Darwin in 1859 and that
was the step that's that was the key
step that that was a sort of Copernican
version for biology that puts us in
nature part of nature everything we've
done since then has cemented our
position in nature and yet you know
we're a paradox we do have this sort of
conundrum position which is that we
accept that we are part of nature where
we're an animal we have the same DNA
same cell structure blah blah blah and
yet the two of us
talking 7,000 miles away over the
Internet's we've just managed to get
this to work and it word flawlessly the
first time because there's such advanced
creatures yes listener it really but
good so I want to I would I love the
idea of the most recent book I don't
I'll confess I don't love the title and
I know the title went back and forth and
it ended somewhere unfortunate in my
point of view humanimal right is that
yeah I don't have the most recent book
so in okay it's called the book of
humans and make sense
sure so my um American publishes the
experiment which is a great little
publishing house based in New York they
wanted to try something different than
the need they they suggested to this me
very late in the process so it's very
shortly before before publication and my
initial response was yeah no no you know
I'm not really not really into
neologisms it didn't I you know just
didn't gel with me and they the first
thing was the cover they showed me to
cover with this design on it and it did
make sense because it was a sort of
blending of the words but the second
thing it was a single word argument that
my editor said which was for economics
and I went yeah I see what you've done
there so I went with I've come I will
mention you know I mostly want to say
good things about your book I will
mention one other thing about the
American version which is that you're
British you write as a British person
does with all these funny spellings that
you folks use and someone clearly did a
global search and replace
turning color Co L oh you are into color
Co lor which is too bad because at one
point you are contrasting the British
and American ways of spelling things but
they're both the American way in the
book we spotted that that is correct now
okay
not just my hallucination anyway so it's
a wonderful sort of puzzle of a book
because on the one hand yeah obviously
we human beings are different in some
way and the book does a wonderful job of
pointing out how hard it is exactly to
identify that way because we have so
many similarities with animals
but before we get there I do want to
give some chance to talk about the
previous book or at least the content
therein in the sense that let's lay the
groundwork for understanding who we are
in the animal kingdom by talking about
our genes our DNA what we've learned how
we've diverged from other primates and
so forth so I what is the big big
picture story of humanity over
evolutionary time right so that's a
that's a great question because was a
great question at any point in time it's
a particularly great question right now
because the whole field has gone through
massive a huge revolution which is
ongoing so a revolution that we didn't
really anticipate was going to happen
and it's it's all it's all predicated on
two things the first is that we simply
understand genetics better than now than
at any point in history and then that's
you know that's just the progress of
science the way the code translates into
a lived life of our fundamental biology
we know that better than at any other
time and that's all post human genome
projects which was sort of nominally
completed in 2001 2003 so that's that's
step one but the second thing is that we
invented the technology at the ability
to extract DNA not just from you and me
from living people but from people who
have been dead for thousands hundreds of
thousands tens of thousands of years and
that gave us access to this historical
source in people who you know in the
past we had scarce remains of and most
of our understanding of evolution was
based on paleontology so old bones and
they are still valid they are very very
useful pieces of evidence and in
understanding the story of how we got
from there to here but there's they
limited and the genome is is the richest
source of data is the richest data set
that we're aware of in the universe and
so having access to that unlocking that
meant that well you know all of a sudden
we just suddenly had this amazingly rich
data set
it started with Neanderthals in 2000
eight nine ten soon after that's we had
discovered a in a cave in Siberia just a
little finger bone of a teenage girl and
a single molar tooth which is not enough
to say this is a different type of
humans enough to say it's a hominin are
these the does Denisovans do something
yeah exactly yeah they're nice ovens
Denise when you say by the way when you
say Neanderthals you what you mean is we
got their DNA right yeah yeah
so Nelson's first discovered in the
1820s first named in the 1860s always
identified as a separate species from us
they do look a bit different to us big
barrel chests much more muscular sort of
slightly flattened brows heavier heavier
eyebrows bigger nasal capacity so they
were legitimately classed as a different
species to us during the era of
morphology being the primary determinant
which we're still in in back in 2009
Svante Paabo his group managed to get
the full genome out of the untold
specimen and in doing so we suddenly
went well okay with it not only do we
have the whole genome but we can tell
immediately a big outstanding question
from human evolution which is what is
the relationship between Homo sapiens
and Homo neanderthalensis we can
calculate using DNA the when when our
species diverged in time which we now
think is around 600,000 years ago which
which roughly fits with what the bones
told us as well and what what the
trajectory from Africa and into Europe
Neanderthals were primarily a European
or Eurasian species whereas Homo sapiens
started in Africa and but but crucially
and this is the really exciting thing
the the evidence was unequivocal is
unequivocal that there was what what
geneticists euphemistically refer to as
gene flow events between such a sexy
term I know yeah it's not really a great
chat up like that is you know genetics
is fundamentally about sex and families
but we introduced all of these terms to
make it sounds so
boring as unbelievable but yeah so one
week when we got the neanderthal genome
2009 we then have unequivocal evidence
that there were gene flow events between
Homo sapiens and Homo neanderthalensis
and we then we could identify bits of
the genome in living people which we now
know are derived from Neanderthals and
so you know I I known you and I can tell
from looking at you that you have
European ancestry as do I basically all
European they're all people of recent
European ancestry have approximately one
to two percent the ANATEL DNA which we
can only tell by having the full
neanderthal genome now this throws the
whole field of sort of species
definitions of taxonomy into into
disarray and and ie this this appeals to
me because I'm some sort of opposed to
taxonomy in in many ways I Dawkins is
phrase which i think is very elegant and
very accurate is that we suffer as a
species from the tyranny of the
discontinuous mind we obsessively try to
put things in neat boxes and listen I
with apologies to you if I say this I
say this in public but never to actually
a physicist that I'm talking to you
biology is I get physics Envy because in
general I think of physics has been
quite reductionist and that your boxes
are quite neat biology is just a science
of exceptions it's incredibly messy
every time we come up with a rule the
first thing you do is look for
exceptions to it and there always are
them so you know this bill is Homo
neanderthalensis a different species
from Homo sapiens well yes in because we
decided it was the species definition
says that two separate species are
organisms that cannot reproduce and I
make fertile offspring that's what I was
taught right but I'm looking at you know
they did that yeah here we are I'm
looking at the fertile offspring of a
Neanderthal and Homo sapiens mating
admittedly forty to fifty thousand years
ago and that says well either the
species definition is wrong homeland
silences and Homo sapiens are not
separate species or what I think
I'm not sure it matters because I think
that it doesn't inform the experiment
that you have to ask which is
fundamental to the scientific process
are we wedded to a definition to such an
extent that it stops you asking what
these creatures did rather than what
they are and I think that a lot of
science is slightly paralyzed by that's
you know by our obsession with holding
on to you know what a thing is I suppose
in in in planetary physics that the
equivalent is is the Pluto story Ludo
yeah yeah exactly and there's a my mind
was changed by reading Mike Brown's book
about it Mike Mike was a previous
podcast guest and my attitude was look
you know Pluto's been a planet it's in
the textbooks less his Quetelet doesn't
who gets hurt by calling it a planet and
his response was it helps organize our
understanding of the world you know
we're gonna go out there and look at
other stars and the planets around them
and it will be useful to future
generations to have a definition for
what's the planet and what's not and in
his mind there are no definitions of
planets which would include Pluto
without also including thousands of
other things so I think that made that
that made sense to me you know the
question is what is the usefulness to us
as scientists I think that is exactly
right right but it is it is how they how
it informs the question that you're
asking
there's another example which I wrote
about in an earlier book when I was
talking about the origin of life and the
the the historical obsession with trying
to define what life is I argue has
actually fundamentally hampered the
experiments to determine what the origin
of what would occurred during
abiogenesis when when when chemistry
became biochemistry and and the reason
for that is because for a long time
since he since the beginning of the 20th
century people have been thinking about
what life is rather than what life does
and as soon as you start looking for the
fundamental basis of what life does
rather than trying to pin it down and
say this is the sort of Platonic ideal
of a living thing or a planet if it's
Pluto or a species if we're talking
about how many
and with sapiens at home and tolerances
as soon as you sort of release yourself
from those shackles you can just ask a
much more interesting question which is
well what is the common behavior of a
cell of every single cell which says
this is the this is what a living system
yeah is rather this is what a living
system does I mean III do you think come
III I'm this is deep philosophical
waters that we could potentially wade
into here I'm not sure how I feel about
this attitude to be honest because you
know I look at people who have argued
about the definition of life and I don't
agree with any of them and one of the
reasons I don't agree with any of them
is because they almost always include
the fact of natural selection and
biological evolution and my attitude as
physicist is like if I took a bunch of
atoms and one by one made a cat out of
them you know a sterile cat that could
not possibly reproduce you know I've
made that and it's walking around and
it's meowing and it's never gonna
reproduce there's no biological
evolution natural selection involved but
you can't possibly tell me the cat's not
alive and so I think that there is a
even though it's frustrating and
occasionally unhelpful there is
nevertheless value in having these
debates about how we should draw the
lines knowing that they could always be
adjusted and we could always learn new
things and we could always do it better
I think that's right but I'm gonna I'm
not just playing to the audience here
we're playing to the interviewer here I
think there is a better understanding of
what life does rather than what life is
and it is a basic physics principle and
I think that biologists have really
misunderstood or haven't paid attention
to basic physics and it is the second
law of thermodynamics because what life
does is is that it temporarily
contravenes no it doesn't contribute I
have to get my language exactly right
hit oh I'm just gonna ignore yeah you're
gonna you're gonna get my other hot
buttons here it doesn't contribute
because because your laws especially no
Atomics are non-negotiable they are
non-negotiable but the analogy I used in
that book and I've used in in lectures
and TV programs is
life is the only thing that is sat at
the table in a casino continuously for
the last 4 billion years we reduce
negative entropy right that is what
living systems do we and until us our
cells are ordered States until we die
and then they then they submit to the
will of the universe has that work with
you you know it's all true
but the process of keeping our bodies in
homeostatic order I also have Antonio
Damasio coming up on the podcast overall
increases the entropy of the universe
the way that I like to put it is that
it's not that life either contravenes or
even temporarily resists the second law
of thermodynamics life is an expression
of the second law of thermodynamics it
relies on the second law of
thermodynamics because if we were in
thermal equilibrium there wouldn't be
any life life is one of the ways in
which entropy increases well I can't
deny that and I would be foolish to deny
that in conversation with a physicist
but would it what that that sort of
slightly philosophical Asif II of
science contexts says in a metabolic way
and this is where I think it's important
for an for informing your experiments as
as a biological researcher at lab and at
the bench is then it says that life is a
process of extracting energy from its
environment and utilizing that energy
and that is a manifestation of I mean
it's a source from shooting all right
this is this all really what you just
said anything it is important I think
the biologists don't always take it very
seriously see you know I mean I went
into my core I think it is probably the
most powerful idea that anyone's ever
come up with it is difficult to conceive
of life in the rest of the universe that
doesn't work in a Darwinian process
that's not to say that that is not the
case but it's just like I can't cuz my
imagination is not not rich enough to
imagine a non Darwinian process but
further than that I think that one what
underlies Darwinian processes is
especially when you're considering the
the origin of life is a metabolic
process is extracting useful energy from
the environments and and
talking about this because we you know
we were thinking about taxonomy and and
categorization I I think it's in
inherently importance in this regard
because yeah you've got to think about
what an organism is doing at the origin
of life which then puts you in a
particular position on earth so you know
you say well one of the classic
questions is is a is a is a flame a
living organism because it behaves in a
very similar way in terms of extracting
energy from the environment it has a
source it needs to be can be continuous
if you if you feed it is it is that a
living thing
is a crystal a living thing and this is
an idea that Schrodinger investigated
because it's capable of reproduction no
I don't think so it looks a bit like it
has characteristics of natural selection
the information that has been
transferred from generation to
generation that isn't modified though
and so piling those things on top of
each other if we need a sort of
framework in order to understand what
life does rather than what life is I
think you have to start with the basics
which is energy extraction from from the
environment natural selection comes
after that why this is important is
because their biology is so ridiculously
complicated that we try and break down
the processes of genetics and cellular
mechanics and you know metabolic
pathways and and stuff like that and
it's very hard to break the circle
because you've got DNA which encodes RNA
which makes proteins and proteins do
stuff and the proteins many proteins are
involved in making DNA which in order to
continue this cycle so how do you break
that that deadlock how could he possibly
have started also right exactly now
we've got a reasonable model how the
information process started with
actually it probably it looks like that
it started with RNA or rather than DNA
which is a simpler but less robust
molecule and can store information you
know the concept of the original gene
which is simply a replicating thing a
unit of replication but no one ever
thought to save that process doesn't
occur unless
you have metabolic input the whole
concept of the primordial soup or the
primeval soup which was first formulated
in the first couple of decades of the
20th century by - in the independent by
haldane and by operon in Russia it's a
very sticky name for it which i think is
part of his successes and as an idea the
in the 1950s 1953 there is the classic
Yuri Miller experiment where Miller was
a PhD student who asked to do this
experiment where he was sealed a bunch
of simple chemicals you know water [ __ ]
dioxide methane in a sealed tube put
10,000 volts across it and just let it
stew and his supervisor Yuri said you
know I'll give you two weeks after four
days the whole clear liquid goes Brown
they take they extract it and it's full
of amino acids right amino acids being
building blocks of life and everyone
goes you know you've created life it's a
really important and interesting
experiment that but it doesn't do what
life does yeah it's a it's a the
thermodynamics of that chemistry is over
once that is reacted right there is no
incentive for that reaction to continue
and what life is is a continuous
chemical reaction a chemical reaction
which is sustained and has been
sustained for four billion years without
break so the concepts of the premium
primordial soup and the Yuri Miller
experiment they're interesting they
don't tell you where life came from
because they don't replicate what life
does so concepts like you know people
say we need a bottle of lightning so you
need some energy source well we're not
powered by lightning some people say you
know Darwin talked about the warm little
ponds and if he got the chemistry right
on the surface of the earth heated by
the Sun or whatever then that is a
possible way to think about how simple
chemicals become more complex chemicals
or in modern parlance how chemistry
becomes biochemistry right except we're
not powered by the Sun the Sun you know
we do no one thought to say well what
does life actually do there are no
organism whatever that we there are
pants are powered by the Sun but that's
that there are later developments in
evolution you know we're powered with
with we're powered by metabolism were
powered by by proton gradients by by
extracting energy by putting energy on
by putting high-energy things on one
side of a barrier and low energy on the
other side and letting it run from one
one to the other and that's how all life
is powered so the audience should know
in case they haven't figured out already
that you've also written a book about
the origin of life yeah we won't get a
tweet we didn't plan this conversation
at all but this is planning that's okay
no no our environments I think the
introduction visits and biology is
perfect it is and in fact I could you
know we could go on about nothing but
this but I really there's some
interesting stuff about humanity that I
want to get to yeah so yeah I mean we're
we're the endpoint of these billions of
years of biological evolution but so at
some point regardless of one's opinions
about the usefulness of categorizations
and taxonomy
there's something that we call Homo
sapiens so like for the for the non
biologists out there just give us the
rough guide to when did human beings
when when did we first have Homo sapiens
and when you know what made us different
from the other great apes that were
related to like what is the distinction
there okay so in having dis taxonomy now
I'm gonna adhere to it now for the
purpose for the useful purposes of this
conversation
so anything in the genus Homo
we refer to as human so this is a genus
that emerged a couple of million years
ago the oldest is is Homo habilis which
literally means handyman when I come and
talk you know why we call it that and
there have been a few maybe a bit
somewhere between five and ten depending
on how you define them versions of
humans over the last couple of million
years we are the last remaining member
of that's of that family with the last
remaining
you go back a hundred thousand years and
we've got how many an tolerances which
is in the an atolls we've got the
Denisovans which don't have a
designation as a separate species but
almost certainly you know were as much
as how many Ana talents this was and
then there's earlier versions such as
Homo erectus Homo antecessor
mo heidelbergensis and they all have
different characteristics some derived
some new that they're all reflect
adaptations to local environments which
is you know how evolution works and then
there's oddities like Homo floresiensis
so that the funny little Hobbit
creatures the the small sort of meter
high humans that have only been found on
Flores so far but just last week and
another possibly new species of of dwarf
humans was was found near another Island
near there and so they they are all all
of those all of those are categorized as
humans because they we put them into the
genus Homo
now Homo sapiens itself the earliest
versions of homo sapiens
until about two years ago came from the
Rift Valley and we're about two hundred
thousand years old so but particularly
from Ethiopia and we always thought of
that the East Africa being the sort of
nursery of humankind in in that sense
the couple year late 2017 it was some
fossils that have been found in the 20th
century in Morocco in a place called Jeb
Olerud were read ated and they came out
as a minimum of three hundred thousand
years old and they are also Homo sapiens
so we're now beginning to think of I'm a
sapiens as being a sort of a pan-african
species so his species possibly made up
of multiple locations of slightly
different versions of Homo sapiens from
around Africa now so we are
fundamentally in African species and
then something significant happens
between one hundred and fifty thousand
years ago probably around seventy
thousand years ago which is a small band
of them migrated out of africa and that
is the population
from which the rest of Homo sapiens is
is derived the the language as with the
taxonomy is deeply problematic here
because we talked about migrations and
and we think I mean general generally we
think about migrations in modern terms
you know people going from here to there
or deciding that we're going to move
from this place to another place in
evolutionary times we're talking about
migrations that have taken thousands of
years so they talk about the Out of
Africa event is an event that takes
thousands of years then migrating at the
rate of you know a mile per year it's a
slow diffusion more than like picking up
stakes and moving thousands yeah exactly
I said one of my lectures is about
timescales in in science in general and
how you know people like you think about
timescales as you know billions of years
as a heartbeat people like me think of
10,000 years as being a flash in the pan
you know much more much happier with
with hundreds of thousands or millions
and then you know you got the quantum
physicists who are talking about time
scales which are unimaginable
unimaginably small so there's that
scalar thing I find that one of the
biggest problems in the sort of popular
discourse of human evolution is
recognizing the rate of change which is
immensely slow in terms of human
appreciation so there was the Out of
Africa event taking tens of thousands
years Homo sapiens then spreads around
the world some we move out of Africa
some go east towards Europe
sorry west towards Europe those are the
ones that have the gene flow events
within the a Natale's
some go further east and they have gene
flow events with the Denisovans and
generally we spread all over the world
and bye-bye well like you know 40,000
years ago we are everywhere apart from
the Americas because that does it here
yeah that didn't really happen until
about 20,000 years ago when that's the
during the last ice age so much of the
waters of the oceans are sucked up into
glaciers and so sea level is much lower
what is now the Bering Straits was just
LAN
- continuous land between Siberia and
what is now Alaska and there is a
movement of people across from what is
now Siberia into what is now Alaska and
then the seas rise 11,000 years ago and
that population is cut off and they are
the founding indigenous people of the
Americas we now know with great
certainty because of genetics that all
the pre European colonization
populations of north and south america
are derived from that from that original
founding population around about 20,000
years ago yeah you know so that's that's
the basic story that's how we got there
and and one of the things I just don't
want - it doesn't sort of
chronologically belong here we don't
want to forget it
one of the things I learned from your
book is this transition from 24 pairs of
chromosomes to 23 pairs of chromosomes
and how that separates humanities genus
homo from the other great apes and
theists explain to the audience what
that is and maybe speculate a little bit
about what that meant for why we're
special yeah yeah that's it's it's a
really good point and and it's a point
that comes up and it's quite useful in
in having arguments with creationists I
took to the extent that the pope john
paul ii use this as part of his argument
as to as to why evolution was correct
and it's it's a sort of basic basic
facet of biology we have our genes are
organized into into chromosomes which
are long stretches of DNA which arranged
during a certain point in the cell cycle
in those sort of iconic structures which
look a little bit like our exes or I
talk about them as being like pinched
socks so if you take a pair of socks and
pinch the middle that's kind of like
what chromosomes look like and they are
discrete packages of DNA which vary in
size there's the you know the best the
ones we are most familiar with are the X
and the y so me and you have one X and
one Y the Y is the smallest and I sort
of shriveled piece of stunted chromosome
whereas the X is a sort of magnificent
beast of a chromosome and women have two
x's and we have a an X and a Y in
general
now the
we have humans Homo sapiens have 23
pairs of chromosomes you get one set
from your father via the sperm and one
set by your mother from from her egg so
we have 46 and total 23 pairs so you've
got two pairs of 1 2 pairs of chromosome
2 2 pairs of chromosome 3 bla bla bla
bla bla all the way up to 22 and then
you either have an X and an X or an x
and a y if you are genetically typical
all of the other great apes of which
there are four so that's gorillas
bonobos chimpanzees orangutangs oh is
that four yes and there's this
subspecies of all of them all of those
have 24 pairs of chromosomes so 48 in
total and a few years ago we worked out
how that how that changed so our common
ancestor with chimpanzees and all the
other great apes had 24 pairs 48 but at
some point probably 7 or 8 million years
ago there was an enormous chromosomal
disruption during probably an individual
and normally chromosome chromosomal
disruptions like this are fatal that
this one wasn't and two bits to two
chromosomes in our ancestors fused
together and made chromosome 2 for us so
our chromosome 2 is the fusion of two
ape chromosomes that are stuck together
at some point and instead of killing
that individual which is typical in
situations like that it gave birth to
the rest of humankind if we put it crazy
to even imagine that it wouldn't kill
that offspring you know it's such a
large disruption of how your DNA was
organized yeah there are very few
chromosomal out Marcis of that sort of
scale which are non-lethal down syndrome
is one example so having 3 3 chromosome
20 ones mostly those sort of were there
called translocations mostly those
translocations either result in you know
profound serious diseases like cancers
or they're just lethal early on during
development
you know soon after conception but for
reasons that we don't understand this
was a massive chromosomal translocation
and fusion which resulted not in
lethality but in the birth of you know
our genus the the the reason this is
important biologically is because
there's sort of basic high school level
biology which teaches us about how sperm
and eggs are made and how the process of
the sort of shuffling of our genes as as
you know we have sexual reproduction
occurs and it requires the two
individuals to have the same number of
chromosomes because the chromosomes line
up and they swap bits over with each
other if you've got a different number
of chromosomes then you've got a massive
disjunction you know you can't swap
evenly which mean and that's that's a
lot of the reason why we think that's
having them having different numbers of
chromosomes or why we wouldn't be able
to reproduce with chimpanzees having
said that and this is this roof this is
a reference to what I was saying earlier
about biology being a science of
exceptions paper published a couple of
years ago describes successful hybrids
between species of ecwid so horses horse
to horse type species who had
chromosomal ranges of between sixty and
thirty-one and well remember this paper
landing on my desk because it was I
looked at it and it was one of those
moments where the first reaction is what
and the second reaction is us so
annoying because you know this is like
one of our basic rules basically
anything with the definitiveness and
there's no deal no no you can't you
can't and we don't know how that works
so there isn't a current model of how
that could possibly be the case I mean
in it seems that that first offspring to
have 23 chromosomes had to mate with
somebody probably somebody with 24 right
and and the 23 one out at least in some
subset of the offspring yeah so we don't
know this is another aspect of the sort
of language that we use because we have
such a sort of personal association with
things like sex and reproduction and and
just and to a certain extent
basic mechanisms of biology I think
sometimes we make generalizations which
make a lot of sense but actually don't
necessarily reflect the time scales
involved so yes that mutation had to
happen once but it's more that we have
to think about it conceptually as as an
event rather than a sort of singular
event at the same I mean I I struggle
with this I die with us on the grounds
that it did have to have I mean it
happened once but at the same time you
know can we draw a trajectory back to
that individual or probably not but what
we then begin to look at is the
population within that mutation occurred
and how that was transferred you know
within a population and it becomes a
sort of ancestral pool there's another
example of this which is one that many
of lessons will be familiar with which
is the the birth of eukaryotic life so
life is divided into in our taxonomy
three domains which are bacteria archaea
which are very similar to bacteria but
different enough to be sort of a
different category different domain and
then there's everything else and
everything else is eukaryotes and
eukaryotes includes us and blue whales
and fungus and all plants and and the
the fundamental difference between the
the bacteria in the Archaea and the
eukaryotes is that we have this sub
cellular unit called the mitochondria
and they're the energy generating that's
that's where all the electron transfer
chain that we were talking about earlier
in terms of energy generation occurs now
what we now know and a sort of deeply
heretical thinker called lynn margulis
came up with this as a theory in the
1960s and it and it is unequivocally you
know correct now no no no it's right
yeah exactly was that it was this was an
event where one cell got inside another
cell which happens a lot but in but
normally the the cell that gets inside
the other cell gets consumed as food but
somehow this result in the stable
transfer of one cell becoming inside
another cell and that resulted in the
single birthplace of the origin of all
life that isn't bacteria and isn't
okay again the evidence says this is an
extraordinarily unlikely event and it
and may have happened many times but it
only appears to have survived once and
again it becomes a sort of singular node
on the evolutionary tree of life and an
load from which you know two billion
years later it's me and you having a
conversation I I find this conceptually
hard you know problematic well yeah I
mean it did take a long time and B
exactly because it's rare and I'm sure
that the 23 chromosome sang was also
rare it seems likely to me that it only
happened at once right like you know
once it happens if it's going to be
evolutionarily adaptive if it's going to
be good then it's gonna spread right and
that seems to be what happened rather
than it happening separately all over
the place so that doesn't seem that that
crazy to me
yeah but evolution is is incredibly
creative over long time periods but it's
also incredibly conservative and so you
know we know this just from the way that
the genetic code is constructed so
without getting too technical about this
we have four letters of genetic code but
in genes they're arranged in triplets
and the triplets encode individual amino
acids of which we have xx and all
proteins are made of those those those
20 amino acids in different orders the
three letters of the genetic code and
not even me they're not equally weighted
and there's there's a good eeveelution
Airy reason for that so the first one
sort of determines what type of amino
acid is going to be is it going to be
hydrophilic or hydrophobic the second
one is more specific than that and the
third one has some redundancy in there
so you have in the genetic code in the
way that we arrange those four letters
into triplets there are 64 versions but
there's only 20 amino acids so there's
redundancy in the code which allows this
third letter of a triplet codon to
change without fundamentally screwing up
the amino acid if you
the first one right if you change if you
take a standard protein and change one
amino acid from being hydrophilic to
hydrophobic the chances are you've
broken your protein you know but if you
take the same in amino acid and change
the third codon from from an a to a T or
whatever then you may be just the
difference you may be just encoding the
difference between blue eyes and brown
eyes or you know the subtle differences
between me and you and so evolution is
has the genetic code is conservative in
that sense it has this it has this
built-in mechanism which is that it
doesn't allow it allows experimentation
but it doesn't allow experimentation
which is which is you know sort of
radical what we're talking about are the
great transitions in evolution and they
do appear to be radical things so that
you know things that are sort of an
insanely radical like huge chromosomal
shifts or you know like one organism
swallowing another and not eating it but
instead you know taking some of his
behaviors creating a life together yeah
and then making it matter yeah yeah no
no I mean I get that I think that
there's I think there this actually
remarkably enough reminds me of the
conversation I had with Edward Watts was
a historian of of ancient Rome and
history is the same way as you described
evolution right there's long periods
where it's more or less not much
happening and then suddenly something
dramatic changes because I was asking
about you know the the well-known great
man theory of history like should we
give so much credit to these individuals
when obviously many more people we don't
know about also played a role and his
answer which I thought was very
insightful was most of the time the
great individuals don't matter you know
the same thing would have happened but
at these crucial periods where things
are on a precipice when you're near a
transition then the there could be a
huge impact to a very small number of
people acting in the right way and I
think that the same story could probably
be told genetically rather than
historically I think that's right and
I've spent a lot of time thinking about
this and wrangling with you know my
desire to tell the true story of how
science evolves now how
how you know though what we commonly
refer to as a scientific revolution and
in the last four or five centuries and
of course you know that that view the
Whiggish view of history there you can
draw a line a straight line as we've
historically taught science between I
don't know Aristotle all the way to
through Darwin through Faraday through
Einstein and to Hawking and you know
those things are easy to do do they
represent how science and how knowledge
is actually transferred well probably
not at the same time I and I think about
these as nodes as well
Darwin is my man right and that was a
nodal event stuff was different on the
25th of November 1859 than it was the
day before there was a radical shift all
that well there's a post hoc radical
shift but between the publication of a
bit before pre publication of the Origin
species and and afterwards was the idea
in the air well definitely he didn't
conceive of evolution where people were
talking about evolution his grandfather
Erasmus Darwin was talking so it was a
key proponent of thinking about
evolution
Lamarque who in the UK at least we we
kind of mock for getting his his theory
of evolution wrong acquired
characteristics the whole idea that
giraffes have long necks because during
their lives they stretch to reach the
tallest tallest branches and and that
characteristic is passed on to the next
generation well you know he was a good
scientist he had a theory and it was a
theory that was based on observations
and it was wrong and it's just really
unfair to mock him for that in France
they don't mock him they have a la Marck
day and I think that's actually while
reading your book was wondering if we
could imagine alien species which did
evolve through Lamarckian means like
going to work out would make their
children stronger as well as themselves
yeah I I think that is perfectly
plausible I don't I don't think we take
much imagination to come up with her and
actually adore Winnie and Lomb
Lamarckian process and we mustn't forget
I don't write about it in the last book
but you make Darwin didn't answer all
the questions of evolution in 1859 he
got the he got the groundwork
revolutionarily right and we've spent
the next 106
years trying to disprove him and
basically failing in every juncture he
was pretty Lamarckian about many aspects
he didn't he didn't know genetics he
didn't know about genes he didn't know
what the unit of selection was that
didn't come until the 1930s and what we
refer to as neo-darwinism and and he
thought that there was evidence for
acquired characteristics being passed on
at least in plants from generation to
generation and again you know it's a
sign of a good scientist to come up with
ideas which you which subsequently turn
out to be yeah
incorrect well we're pro Darwin here on
the mindscape podcast as metal matter of
official doctrine so even probe the mark
he was a good scientist scientists
should be allowed to be wrong but all
this talk of you know turning points and
phase transitions brings up something I
wanted to ask about because we have
clearly a turning point when Homo
sapiens comes on the scene roughly three
hundred thousand years ago is that a
fair number yeah but then there's this
even more mysterious turning point forty
or fifty thousand years ago yeah where
we didn't change that much biologically
you make the point in the book that if
you brought a two hundred thousand year
old Homo sapiens up and you know gave
them a shave and put them in nice
clothes you wouldn't maybe even tell on
the street certainly not streets of Los
Angeles that they were you know in any
way unusual but there is this more
cultural intellectual uh you know
cognitive shift I'm not sure how to put
it just forty years forty thousand years
ago yeah that's exactly right and this
this is the paradox this is this is the
subtitle of the of the book is how Homo
sapiens became nature's most paradoxical
creature and I think that's a useful way
to think about it because we do have
this weird stasis between three hundred
thousand years ago and say let's say
fifty thousand forty thousand years ago
where we don't change physically we
don't really change genetically very
significantly there's none of those big
chromosomal shifts that we just talked
about in terms of going from you know 23
to 24 chromosomes or whatever none of
that happens there it there is definite
genetic change but but not so much that
we're all quite clearly the same species
and clearly capable of interbreeding but
and there is there is this sudden
emergence and you know evolutionary
timescales we're talking about so sudden
meaning tens of thousands of years of
what we might refer to as behavioral
modernity so that the things the
characteristics that we recognize in
ourselves and so they are things like
high high levels of skill in in terms of
tool-making in terms of manual dexterity
and that's manifested in the
archaeological remains in the in the the
way the tools became much more
sophisticated in the way that we are
clearly in control of manipulating fire
which is a very important step in our
evolution something that Darwin thought
was was sort of quintessential to humans
but also we see the emergence of things
like abstract thought and that's
manifested that manifests as art so we
have the cave paintings we have the the
earliest examples of figurative art so
things like the the Lovan mensch the
lion man of holy holy strange startle
which is this just beautiful sort of 12
inch statue carved out of a tusk of a
man with seven stripes down his left arm
which we think might be tattoos because
we think that they had tattooing kids at
that time but it has the head of a cave
lion now it's beautiful right it's a
it's a work of art it's beautiful in
whatever manifestation you're through
you're thinking about it but it also
shows this it shows aspects of
behavioral modernity it shows that the
mind behind it was not substantive ly
different from our minds today it shows
creativity it shows the ability to
imagine a chimera a beast that does not
exist it can't exist in isolation so it
must be part of a series so it shows
immense manual dexterity the selection
of the tools require the selection of
the material required it shows you know
some sort of totemic importance of lions
at that stage we can only guess as to as
to what those things meant but the
important thing is it shows that
person behind the creation of that thing
was was fundamentally no different in
terms of their cognitive abilities to us
and we don't see that earlier we don't
see the continuous you know we see
flashes of this flashes of things that
you might call art or abstract displays
of thought but from about 40,000 years
ago we see it continuously and we see it
all over the world and so people have
referred to this as the cognitive
revolution I'm not I'm not keen on that
phrase because I think revolutions
should take short I think they should
take you know 24 hours or a week or
something rather than 10,000 minutes but
we see the lion man and then we see
these these Venus figurines all over
Europe which which is they tend to be
smaller little amulets of the female
form often with very exaggerated sexual
characteristics so people have
speculated that they are to do with
sexuality or reproduction I I sort of
don't care because I we don't know what
the mind of someone else
the Joko making lectures it's hard
enough to know the mind of someone
you're actually married to let alone
someone who died 40,000 years ago so
they might have been toys they might
have been dolls maybe they were totemic
reproductive symbols we don't know to me
I think we actually under appreciate
maybe the appearance of these artistic
figures in in the following sense you're
not only the carved figures but the cave
paintings we're so used to doing this
right this is very human making art but
there had to be a first time that it
happened and that's kind of amazing like
we don't we don't think of even our
closest relatives in the great apes as
making representations of themselves is
that I don't think it's ever happened so
is there any idea of what caused it you
know or is there there doesn't seem to
be as we said any physiological change
going on
no and that's exactly right we don't see
any sort of manifestations of this sort
of creative process in any other
organism apart from Homo sapiens with
one caveat we're checking we can talk
about in just a minute
and that is weird so why would that be
and the truthful answer is what we don't
know right so the the speculation and
why the cognitive revolution I'm not
going to call it that the transition to
behavioral modernity is important as a
concept is because it represents a a big
shift in our evolutionary trajectory
which doesn't appear to be modulated by
by genetics by physiological order or
genetic change but but in fact is is an
evolution which is predicated on the
social interaction and so one analogy
which I quite like is that if if we
think about our biology as being
hardware and our culture is being
software then what we have gone through
in that transitionary period is we've
shifted so much of the emphasis of our
of our biological makeup from hardware
to software right so that the hardware
doesn't fundamentally change but it is
in the interaction of software in the
cultural domain how we interact with
other organisms you know in the same
species of us as us that has
fundamentally changed and form
formulated the basis for for all of the
creation of these things you we can
speculate reasonably that I don't know
you know being able to carve a flute or
make the best possible tools or painter
you know a Megalosaurus or like on a
cave wall we can speculate that that is
an attractive characteristic because you
know that that is something that other
or other members of your tribe will look
at and say hey he's the guy who does the
Megalosaurus cave paintings and
therefore he's a successful person and
therefore from a reproductive sense we
might want to reproduce with him more
and so that's a characteristics which is
which is going to be passed on through
the generations the fact that it's not
necessarily genetically encoded I think
is really important and and this is
really the key idea in the book that the
emergence of social behaviors to
transfer from hardware to software
that's as we've we've talked about that
for a for a few years now as in stuff
that Jared Diamond has written
extensively at
and and Darwin talks about it in in 1871
in the in the in the descent of man
why it happened and the mechanism by
which it happened in terms of how our
populations were structured well that's
brand-new and that that's an idea which
emerges out of well to research centers
so basically UCL which is where I'm
affiliated and and also Harvard so a guy
called Joseph Heinrichs at Harvard and
it it's it's kind of remarkably unsexy
in in its genesis it's it seems to be
determined by population size also want
when we model these these things
mathematically and this corresponds with
what the archaeological record looks
like it appears to be the case that as
population sizes increase you see a
simultaneous expansion in these sort of
creative artifacts so we see what it
looks like is we see the sudden
expansion in the in in the complexity of
the archaeological record and what the
mathematical models suggest is that this
coincides with our populations suddenly
increasing in size and so the this is
kind of the key idea demographic
transitions how we talk about it and
it's all to do with information transfer
right so we have very uneven
distribution of expertise in humans
unlike all other species you know
physics I know biology if you need to
get your car fixed you take it to the
shop if you want to know how to do a
thing that you don't know how to do what
do you do you ask someone who knows how
to do it that the mathematical models
suggest that if a population size is
above a certain threshold then the
transmission of that information occurs
with great efficiency and when it's when
your population is below a certain size
thresholds then it occurs with great
inefficiency and this omission size or
density it's probably a combination of
both both of those things so you say the
way I described it I mean it sounds very
academic and very mathematical but it
actually kind of makes a lot of sense in
an age before right
ting stuff down where you can record
things and therefore pass on that
information on Wikipedia or in a book
the ability to have if I'm the guy in
the village who makes the flutes if you
want to know how to make a flute you
come to me right but if there's only ten
people then they you've all got to learn
how to make the flute from me and you've
all got to learn it really accurately in
order to pass that that peak that unit
of information flute making into the
next generation if the population is
very large it means that inefficient
transfer of flute making skills can pass
to many many people and that can be
passed on and that can be a continuous
unit which can transfer both
horizontally and vertically through the
generations and and that coincides that
that population expansion that transfer
of information about whatever the unit
of information that appears to coincide
with the sudden emergence of things like
figurative art or great complexity and
tools and and it all it happens all over
the world we've only talked about Europe
and the sort of cave paintings because
we have a very Eurocentric view of
evolution that's changed in the last
couple of years the earliest figurative
art was the lion mane it's now a Banting
painting in Borneo and I said that was
only published last year and it's about
the same date but the the overlap the
error bars pointed Borneo being older we
see it in African populations we see it
in the Middle East and as populations
grow we see sudden expansions and in the
indicators of behavioral modernity we
also see the opposite in one particular
example which has some cultural
sensitivity and that is Tasmania
so has until the last glacial maximum
ten in eleven thousand years ago
Tasmania is attached to mainland
Australia and there are people the
indigenous people are threw outs that
those those joined Islands the Seas
rises the glossiest melts it has mainly
become separated becomes an island we've
got no evidence that there was
they were seagoing people on the
indigenous people Tasmania was seagoing
and that there's transfer between
Tasmania and mainland Australia so
they're an isolated population for the
last 10,000 years now what we see in the
archaeological record is very
interesting because at a time 12,000
years ago we see a sort of standard
level of complexities of tools a tool
set which is a few dozen by the time
European colonizers arrived in the 17th
18th century on mainland Australia the
tool set for indigenous people of the
Australia's it has gone up a standard
ratings in the now now and the hundreds
but the tool set of the indigenous
people of Tasmania has dropped to below
20 we see specific examples of this
which is the loss of things like fine
tooth bone harpoons and it looks like
the people of Tasmania had returned to
being forages on the seafront rather
than hunting for fish beyond the barrier
using harpoons and when we've got some
records of that from from history such
as Cook's men James Cook's men as they
were as they were arriving in places
like Tasmania we said that the
indigenous people expressed shock that
they were hunting for cartilaginous fish
we see the disappearance of costliness
fish bones and the archaeological record
now I mean listen if talking talking
about this is it does have cultural
sensitivities it's not saying that
there's any you know not making any
judgment about the people of the
indigenous people of Tasmania during
that that's evolutionary trajectory just
fact that they did not continue to
develop technologically in the same way
that mainland in Australia indigenous
people did which was based on constant
interaction with other groups travel
sharing of information rather than a
very isolated population it's very
consistent with pointed Geoffrey West
made on an earlier podcast that
innovation happens not linearly with
population but you know
some higher power you know you you
innovate more and more quickly as the
density of interactions gets more and
more vivid and vibrant and I think that
you know it also speaks to this question
of whether or not scientific
technological intellectual progress is a
story of a few geniuses or something
more collective because certainly if you
just listed the great breakthroughs
there would be a few geniuses who get
the credit but only because in
retrospect only because they were
embedded in these larger communities of
thought and the most human beings lived
before the Industrial Revolution and yet
most good ideas in some sense happened
afterward and I think that the it's not
that we human beings have gotten better
but the environments that we're in have
changed dramatically I think that's
exactly right and so we do legitimately
say that's that's you know Darwin was a
genius and Newson was a genius and
rosalind Franklin was a genius and and
those people in which the changes pivot
it's those those nodal events in the
history of science or the history of
thought the environment in which they're
in is the is is the stew from which they
are allowed to emerge so that the I
think there's a difference between the
myth of the genius and the myth of the
sort of heretical lone genius those two
things are slightly different I do think
for example that Darwin had both the
well 99% grit facilitated by being
extremely wealthy and therefore didn't
not having to work it helps it certainly
does but he he carved out that theory
over 20 or 30 years after being on the
Beagle so them you know he didn't go to
the Galapagos and see the finches and go
holy [ __ ] that's evolution he went back
home and spent years working on pigeon
bones and and writing to literally
hundreds of people to ask for bits of
information where he was carving out his
his one big argument it was that
intellectual environment that enabled
him to see further right to have that
that that 1% which
from being one of the great scientists
into what I argue is the greatest
scientist but and we mustn't forget that
Alfred Wallace came up with exactly the
same idea yeah in far less detail at
exactly the same time wrote to Darwin
and said here's my idea because I'm out
in Indonesia at the time Darwin yep yeah
you've got it - yeah yeah and in 1858
they they announced it together so a
year before Saddam's ill and Wallace was
absent but it was presented it it's the
Linnean Society together as which I
think befits the quality of the of the
idea it also reflects the nature that
this is an idea that is in the air right
exactly and I think that's part of the
the lesson of how these developments
happen but I don't want to you know
we're gonna have to come to a close
pretty soon so I don't want to go too
far in the spirit of your book you know
that we've just been talking about
things that make human being special
much of the point of your book is to say
that many of the things that we think
make us special are in fact found there
in other species of animals so we talked
about you know tool use and art and so
forth but tool use in particular you do
it you just have a wonderful selection
of examples of tools being used by
non-human animals that takes us down
just a little bit of a path yeah yeah
sure yeah so why don't one of the themes
of all of my work and I think it's
particularly exemplified in this in this
last book in humanimal z-- is that I'm
not really into uniqueness theories I'm
not really into triggers we talk about
nodes these events where things flow
into them and then you know the world
blossoms out of it or new knowledge
blossoms out of it I'd like to revel in
that come in this the complexity and the
sophistication that he's actually how
science work and actually how evolution
works and one of the things that we are
really prone to do is to is to suggest
that there are individual things right
this is the thing that made us human and
and people for hundreds of thousands of
years and continue to this day
to have successful career saying it was
this Darwin said it was fire tools and
speech other people have said you know
serious people have said that it was
there's the pyro philic ape theory that
it is fire that is the determining
factor in switching us from being the
earlier versions of ourselves into the
versions that we recognize today other
people are suggested you know
hallucinogenic drugs it is all of those
things and none of the above and I think
what's in what's important is to
recognize that having the biological
framework to manipulate file speakers
we're doing or the physical capability
and the neural capability to carve a
stone something that dolphins will never
be able to do because they need their
forelimbs to paddle so they're fused
together they can't hold things they
will never carve a hand axe they will
never carve a flute dolphins will never
be able to manipulate fire mostly
because they live in the sea and that
that means that their evolutionary
trajectory is fundamentally different to
ours I I don't think we're very good at
recognizing the sort of cosmic
happenstance the environment in which
evolution happens and and I think we're
very attracted to looking at behaviors
that look familiar to us because we do
them and then we see an animal doing it
and then just automatically saying well
the chimpanzee does this we're closely
related to chimpanzees therefore this is
an evolutionary behavior which we have
inherited from our common ancestors with
with chimpanzees well we just don't know
that they've they're often very hard
things to test
Tullius used to be thought of as
uniquely human we now know because we
watch nature documentaries that loads of
well all the great apes and loads of
other primates use tools sticks wooden
and stone tools we now know that the
corvids
and other birds are sophisticated tool
use in fact tool uses is is we are
obligate tool users which means we can't
function without tools and we now think
that around about 1 percent of
or obligate tool users which doesn't
sound like a lot it's one at 100 but
that is literally thousands of species
yeah what's more interesting than the
number is the range so lots of mammals
do it we do it other primates do it but
also do it right you mentioned dolphins
yeah also there's one at one example of
dolphins using tools which i think is a
fundamental interest because it's the
mechanism by which the transfer of that
tool skill is looks more like the way
that we do it which is that we talk to
each other me you know what we're doing
now is sharing ideas the the the example
in dolphins is is wonderful a pod of
bottlenose dolphins in Australia and
Shark Bay and Australia have been
studied for decades were observed doing
something peculiar a proportion of them
about 50% of them were observed doing
something peculiar which is that they
would swim down to the sea floor and and
sort of work a sponge onto their rostrum
which is their beak and well initially
the researchers didn't know why why they
did this but then when they were diving
with them it was observed that they were
using these sponges as protection for
when they were foraging on the sea floor
because they're eat there it's rocky and
you don't want to scratch up your beat
because that can get infected and that's
that's bad so this is an example of one
animal using another animal to hunt for
a third animal that's relatively rare we
kind of do that sometimes but that is
unusual in itself the story gets much
more interesting in the 2010 when the it
was worked out why only a proportion of
the dolphins were doing this which is
only females do it right so no males
have ever been observed sponging like
this and that is difficult to explain
you don't see any differential sexual
success between the males and the
females who sponge and you don't but
it's it's hard to understand why
something which clearly has benefit is
only being done by females I mean there
are lots of obvious jokes to make at
this point but it may be just the cells
are idiots
that's rude to male dolphin but there's
a second on top of that when the
genetics of the Dolphins that are doing
the sponging behavior was looked at
they're not particularly closely related
so all the females have been doing this
they're not mother and daughter they're
not sisters
so this looks like a behavior which is
spread laterally that is being either
learnt or taught and there is a sort of
academic distinction between those two
which I'm a bit fuzzy on I'm not that
keen on what the distinction is but one
of the ways I framed the book is that we
are lots of animals learn but only
humans teach which is not quite I mean
there's there's nuance within that it
looks like this behavior within the
sponging dolphins is is a it's
definitely a learned behavior it may be
a tort behavior we have to remember that
most organisms spend almost all of their
time unobserved by us there's an even
there's a third thing that emerges from
this which I just think is wonderful you
can you can look at the pattern of
behavior of the sponging behavior in the
Dolphins that do this and we can check
the relatedness via DNA which also means
we can we can sort of trace back through
time and the evolutionary pedigree of
where that behavior actually started and
it starts with a single origin we're
talking about single origins again yeah
it looks like it was six generations ago
generational time in a dolphin in a
bottlenose dolphins around about 25
years so that puts it to an individual
female in the mid 19th century
who we refer to as sponging Eve who I
don't know one morning gone up put a
sponge on its nose seems like a good
thing to do lone dolphin genius
I know 150 years later they're all do
well not all of them all of the females
are doing it and the males have yet to
carry to catch on it's a wonderful
example it demonstrates so many things
about the cognitive abilities of
different animals the transfer of
information between individuals within
that then that grew but I think more
than anything it tells us something
terribly important which is the best
thing a scientist can ever say about
anything which is we don't really know
and it's also a good thing to contrast
not only with
human beings but with other tool using
animals I mean you have the wonderful
example in your book of the birds that
spread wildfires intentionally I Darwin
and others thought of us human beings as
the animals that use fire but that's
clearly not true that's that's right
right I mean it turns out a few animals
are dependent on fire and utilize fire
in various capacities chimpanzees in
vongole and Senegal have a sort of
sophisticated understanding of the
regular the annual wildfires they will
stay near fires which very dangerous and
capricious they will cruise in as soon
as the fires have gone out and forage
for semi Cooke's organisms you know
there are beetles that head towards fire
with infrared detectors on their bodies
because they will plant their eggs in
recently burnt logs so there are plenty
of animals lots more plants that
understand that fire is is part of their
natural ecology but the idea that it's
essential for humans is is very powerful
for a number of obvious reasons one it
allows us to keep warm as we migrate
away from the equator so that
facilitates us moving around the world -
it has social importance to this day
that is I'm sitting two meters from our
fire there you go which half an hour ago
my children were sitting watching
Independence Day now they've got a bed
but but also it's an external stomach
right eating is a risky business because
our mouths very close to our there on
our faces in general and so near to our
eyes if you've if you've got your head
down in some food you're spending a lot
of time eating which increases the risk
of you being eaten so if you can spend
less time eating then that isn't that
potentially increases your survival
so we pre digest our food by cooking it
right we spend less time cheering we
spend less time eating because it is
semi digested before we even put it in
our mouth so that all of these things
are essential parts of our of our
development you know we are obligate
fire users so this notion that we are
the only organism that can create fire
and new is is different from saying that
there are lots of organisms that are
dependent on fire yeah now now that was
that that was that was a robust and good
and interesting important theory until
about I think it was December 2017 so my
editors hate me for constantly updating
books after I just need them to stop for
like a year so he can catch up they just
don't do it but it was it was the
publication in the scientific literature
of the description of three types of
Australian Raptors so Hawks that hang
around on the edges of Savannah fires in
Western Australia pick up burning twigs
fly over natural or man-made fire
barriers and drop them in dry areas of
brush and then they go and set it up on
any tree and all of the little critters
the mammals and the lizards that run
away from being burnt to death run away
from these bush fires and into the
mouths of the raptors who have basically
flushed them out now their abscess do
that they flock there are hundreds of
birds in three different species so far
that we've identified that do this and
it in fact explains a lot of spontaneous
fires that occur over man-made or
natural they're natural but they're but
they're not unintentional they're not
bird proof is what they are I think
there's another really interesting point
within this which is that this is
published in the scientific literature
in 2017 Aboriginal Australians have
known about this for maybe thousands of
years it's big fire Raptors fire birds
form part of various Dreamtime
ceremonies some people have even
speculated that this is a behaviour that
humans might have learnt from the birds
I think that is that's speculation
that's very politics I like it but yeah
I don't buy it
no I I'm I'm the same if it were true
this is this is an example of cultural
transmission between species
which is relatively rare but it's it's a
lovely idea I don't think it's
supportable using the evidence to hand
but what it does show very clearly is
what is referred to as indigenous
expertise knowledge right ie Kay that
it's that this is something which has
been known for generations
maybe maybe hundreds maybe thousands of
years amongst one population for which
it's incredibly important it gets
written up in the scientific literature
in 2017 and we all sort of go put it
because it's this incredibly cool thing
yeah it's a ridiculously cool thing but
it just shows the proper engagement this
has worked on by Bob Gosford in
Australia proper engagement with people
with with indigenous expertise results
in much richer science right and I think
so one other example I wouldn't get on
the table while we're listing ways in
which we're not as unique compared to
the rest of the animal kingdom not just
using tools that we find on the ground
but there's examples
you're gonna correct me I hope but in
your book I think it's a kind of
chimpanzee that not only uses Spears but
sharpens them when they go hunting or
even going to war with each other yeah
sure so a lot of the great apes do do
this we know that some orangutangs sharp
and straight stillage they'll select a
stick so it's another example of sort of
the thought process involved and
choosing the right stick which also
called it to do as well they they
they're good at identifying a good stick
for making a tool rather than a bad one
and in fact there's a good experiment
which shows that if you put a so the
Caledonian crows in particular if you
put a good looking hook stick just out
of reach behind the bar but you put a a
not so attractive stick in reach the
Corvis the Caledonian crows will use the
first stick to fish that they can stick
out and so that sort of meta tool use
and that shows you know it's that is
complex cognition required to require to
do that the faun goalie chips the same
ones i was talking about a minute ago in
Senegal they they will take sticks and
they will create Spears out of them
sharpen them with their teeth they'll
strip them and they do this for a
specific slightly grim
reason but then again nature doesn't
care what we think which is that they
like to eat Bush babies and Bush babies
are nocturnal so babies by the way are
not human babies that are sleeping in
bushes they are a form of animal tiny
little mammal yeah yes that's very
audience knows it's it's an important
clarification they are no less cute than
the big guys yeah they've got the big
eyes because they're nocturnal they
slightly off Tintin holes in trees
hollowed out holes and holes in trees
and this has been observed many times if
if you strip away if you if you'd like
reach in and pull away the bark in order
to get to the bush babies they wake up
and they run away and they're much
lighter than chimpanzees they scamper
off to the top of the trees and the
chimps can't get them the faun goalie
chimps take Spears and what they do is
they sneak up on the trees and they will
Jam the spear through the bark having
been sharpened with their teeth and they
will they basically kebab them and they
will they will you know remove a bush
baby on on the stick and they will eat
it straight off the bone it's it's grim
but it's not very effective yeah exactly
nature does not care what what you think
it's a really good example of to use for
specific purposes you know for hunting
again we have taken this to
extraordinary extreme levels in terms of
our sophistication in tool use there's a
Darwinian phrase which which I talk
about a lot in the book is it's a lovely
phrase which is he talks about humans
differing by degree and not by kind now
I it's such an important phrase but it's
one that I contest in some circumstances
I think there's cultural reasons for
that dom's writing in the 1870s where
the question of whether humans had
evolved from earlier Apes was still very
much being debated and so he he he uses
this phrase to say well you know there
is continuity in whatever we look at
between humans and earlier
organisms so we differ by degree and not
not by kind I think that sometimes
that's true with our in the contemporary
age where we're no longer debating that
with other scientists and most sensible
people that you know the now that we are
established as evolved creatures we can
be more honest about the fact that there
are some things which we didn't differ
by degree and there are some things
which which just are so fundamentally
different that they look like they are
different by kind the best example is
what we're doing right now yeah
speech communications symbolic
manipulation of ideas representations we
don't see that in any serious degree in
any other organism the attempts to teach
great apes particularly cocoa in
California giant died last year I think
a slightly absurd experiments and say
much more about us than they do about
gorillas but even even so cocoa had
several a few thousands words but
couldn't do what a three-year-old does
naturally which is to construct her
syntactical a grammatical sentence of
grammar yeah yeah and and I use the
example of the fact that grammar is a
rules-based system that we continually
violate the rules and kids say cute
things all the time because they learn
these rules and they apply these rules
to other words which actually turn out
to be incorrect because we don't follow
the rules my my what the example is in
the book is my daughter says we swimmed
rather than we swam can't blame her for
that can't really punish her yeah I
think this is a stupid language it's a
ridiculous non rules based language but
the fact that she does that intuitively
means that there is an innate
grammatical framework which which is is
part of the complexities of the
physiology the mechanics the anatomy of
being able to speak combined with an
enormous mainframe of you know
processing power in which language is an
inbuilt facility
I think that is not different by degree
I think that is different by by kind
right and I think so just to wrap up
here I mean you've mentioned a couple
times that some of these transitions
that we point to as revolutionary cusps
or turning points or whatever actually
spread out over thousands or tens of
thousands of years presumably a million
years from now future historians are
gonna be saying the same thing about our
ongoing symbolic revolution in the use
of language and information that were in
the middle of right now we're not at the
end of it right can you would you even
dare to speculate a little bit about the
future and where we're going given that
we're still lifting ourselves up by our
bootstraps with this new fangled
technique yeah well no is the answer to
that if it's to do with the timescale
question so it is singularly the
question that I get asked most in public
talks are we still evolving now that
there's there's two ways to answer this
the first is yes we are because
evolution simply means change over time
and as long as we keep having children
by sexual reproduction our children are
genetically different to us and that is
the you know that is the constraints of
difference and natural human variation
the question I think most people are
really asking is are we evolving under
the constraints of natural selection now
the answer to that is there are two ways
to answer that the answer in
evolutionary timescales is yes because
we've got really clear examples over the
last 10,000 years if you wants which is
a blink of an eye in evolutionary
timescales of natural selection
occurring measurably in human
populations all over the world there are
regional adaptations in human
populations which allow have allowed us
to become so globally successful you
know a really fun example we always talk
about is milk drinking that's most most
Europeans can process milk after weaning
after they've been nursed but most
people in history and most people on
earth can't because they're the enzyme
that processes a particular sugar in
milk
lack toes the enzymes called lactase
basically switches off by age five in
most people about 7,000 years ago seven
or eight thousand years ago a population
in Europe who were pastoralists already
developed a mutation a random mutation
which meant that they could continue to
process lactose into adulthood and that
is why me and you can drink tea there's
an interesting sideline to this which is
that in the last couple of years from my
next book is about race and genetics
which is now finished and will be out
next year neo-nazis and white
supremacists have taken this this this
genetic truism as an example of their
own superiority of European superiority
look them there are yeah milk chugging
is a thing and so you go on YouTube and
you look at little chugging Nazis and
they've all got their tops up from
they're quite drunk and they're pouring
gallons of milk all over their faces
which is a just a WoW it's a weird thing
to do they it all European almost all
Europeans are lactose persistent which
is the condition that we're talking
evolved the derived condition that we're
talking about they have failed to notice
that lactose persistence also has
independently emerged in pretty much
every population that has had
pastoralism as part of its evolutionary
trajectory and that includes the Tutsi
in Rwanda the Khoisan in South Africa
southern Africa Middle East and camel
farmers you know it's it's a it's a semi
serious point that I like to make but
then again you know we don't look to
white supremacist for contemporary
understanding it's not the only thing
they have fail to notice though yeah
that that is true that is true now why
did I mention that what we're future in
is hard oh yeah yeah hard to get right
right so that so the the mill drinking
thing is a really good example of recent
evolution local adaptation which is
natural selection isn't quite the right
way to think about it
it is selection but it's more it's what
we refer to as gene
co-evolution so our cultural behavior
which is farming you know pastoralism
has influenced the selection of a random
mutation in our genes so it's a it's
those two things happening masane time
or roughly the same time which is cause
that ability and it seems like that that
is the future in the sense that now that
we cannot only store information in
words and books and so forth and use
that to manipulate ourselves and hand it
down to other people and now we can even
manipulate our genomes the future
evolution of our genome will necessarily
involve coevolution of what happens
through natural selection and what
happens through our external information
processing and gathering and sharing
systems yes definitely true but what is
what I think what I think is apparent is
how unevenly distributed these things
are so so you know the main drivers of
evolution are how many children you have
and how how young they die what what we
know very clearly is that since records
were first taken about infant mortality
in the 19th century that they're very
clear patterns that are lowest levels of
infant mortality were in northern Europe
mostly Scandinavia and the highest
levels were in western Africa now 200
years later one or fifty years later the
infant mortality has dropped all over
the world it's pretty much the same rate
the highest levels of infant mortality
are still in West Africa and the lowest
levels are still in Scandinavia and
America in the UK surprisingly are
somewhere in the middle which is I
always find that a weird stat so that
uneven distribution of this main driver
of evolution around the world may mean
that there is selection in those areas
but it's not universal we do see
glimpses of natural selection or forms
of selection in different populations
have been studied the technological
question I think is really interesting
people have asked me if
the advent of in vitro fertilization has
shifted our trajectory we the estimates
are about five million babies since
nineteen since Louise Brown in 1979-1980
was born have been the result of
in-vitro fertilization and and that
seems like I mean that's a decent chunk
of people five million people if you saw
them at a at a festival yeah I think
that's a lot it's it's it's you know
it's it's one thousandth less than less
than a thousandth of the global
population so relatively small but it's
also massively unevenly distributed it's
a very very Western and technologically
based process and so I think the answer
is probably no probably not a
significant contributor another example
is we've begun to manipulate the
germline of very few diseases that have
been approved so this is pre CRISPR
technology which which is this new gene
editing kit which i think is gonna
prompt a revolution if it hasn't done
already but we've actually chosen to
eradicate a particular type of disease
of mitochondrial disease where they have
a separate genome we take donor
mitochondria from a third individual
third adult and replace the mitochondria
in children who are going to have this
otherwise lethal disease now again we
have eradicate we have changed the
direction those those children would not
have made it to adulthood they would not
have reproduced and that's that that
mutation would have would have died with
them we have replaced that using
technology yeah has it changed evolution
I almost certainly not because it's a
tiny proportion of people for whom this
is has been applied and it will never be
very many people because it is a
mercifully rare disease for an ethical
point of view I think we're at the point
where we the question is not whether we
should do it it's whether we shouldn't
do it right if we if we are capable of
doing this then you have to ask yourself
questions about why you wouldn't want to
do this rather than why you would CRISPR
may change that we saw just before
Christmas the what I think is probably
the greatest violation of bio
logical ethics that I've experienced in
my lifetime which was the announcement
of the birth of two girls in China who
had been genetically edited via CRISPR
by a Chinese not really a reproductive
scientist at all to add an attempt to
make them immune to HIV right it it it
wasn't the right mutation they checked
he checked that it wasn't that it was
the right mutation before it was
implanted into the mother and knew that
it wasn't the right mutation but
implanted them anyway
it is a it is a an ethical and moral
violation the likes of which I haven't
seen I don't think in in my lifetime it
won't be the last one it won't be the
last one I think it may have had the
effect of unifying the community
including China which is traditionally
you know not as accessible in terms of
in terms of openness about what they're
actually doing he was a rogue element
and I think will spend the rest of his
life either in jail or the rest of his
life isn't going to be that long he
won't you're right he won't be the only
one but well at least we're talking
about it yeah you know is it going to
change it our future history I don't
think we're anywhere near understanding
the genome well enough to actually say
yeah we'll check back in 500 years and
see what new things we've learned I I
would love to know where we how we got
from here to there all right I'll let
the audience know one last thing which
is that Adams new book contains a long
and highly entertaining section about
sex yeah we didn't get to talk about
here lots of that I think the motto is
there's plenty of non-reproductive sex
going on everywhere in the animal
kingdom so the idea that sex is just for
reproduction is not a very good one we
did get to talk about it here but I want
people to know it's in the book
yeah I like I say in the lectures I
didn't set out to write a book about
weird animal sex
it just is a book that contains a lot of
weird animal sex what seen you do you
know it's the term
all right Adam Rutherford thanks so much
for being on the podcast Sean thank you
for talking to me is a complete pleasure
I love love having these long-form
conversations where we can really get
stuck in all right good luck with the
book
[Music]
[Music]